welche drogen sind wirklich gefährlich
und gibt es substanzen die man ohne
probleme verwenden kann
eine aktuelle studie hat sieben bekannte
und beliebte drogen miteinander
verglichen
was schadet wem das jetzt in
kriegszeiten fiction
laut einer neuen studie die vor kurzem
in der wissenschaftlichen
fachzeitschrift scientific reports
veröffentlicht wurde ist alkohol 114 mal
tödlicher als cannabis die studie hat
sieben bekannte drogen genauer
untersucht dabei wurde die tödliche
dosis einer substanz mit der menge
verglichen die üblicherweise konsumiert
wird anschließend wurden die drogen in
drei kategorien eingeteilt preisrisiko
risiko und geringes risiko doch was
bedeuten diese ergebnisse um das zu
verstehen
schauen wir uns die gefahren der
beliebtesten drogen einmal genauer an
alkohol alkohol fällt sowohl in der
skala für persönlichen schaden als auch
in der skala für schaden an der
gesellschaft in die kategorie press
risiko das liegt daran dass alkohol
sowohl auf kurze als auch auf lange
sicht sehr tödlich sein kann
die üblicherweise von menschen
konsumierte dosis von alkohol ist nicht
allzu weit von der tödlichen dosis
entfernt über ein viertel aller mit
alkohol verbundenen tode wird durch
direkte überdosen verursacht auf lange
sicht schadet man seinen körper mit
einem erhöhten alkoholkonsum allerdings
auch an emi leberschäden und krebs sind
nur einige der möglichen folgen alkohol
schadet aber auch der gesellschaft ein
autounfall in betrunkenem zustand ist 14
mal wahrscheinlicher als nüchtern viele
unschuldige menschen starben in
autounfällen die von betrunkenen fahrern
verursacht werden zusätzlich er wird
alkohol die gewaltbereitschaft manche
menschen werden betrunken agressiver und
beging schneller verbrechen allerdings
muss man hier auch differenzieren im
vergleich zu anderen drogen ist alkohol
für die gesellschaft nur deshalb so
schädlich weil er so beliebt ist andere
drogen würden wesentlich mehr schaden
anrichten wenn sie so beliebt wie
alkohol werden ich will euch ja keine
angst machen die meisten menschen können
problemlos ihr leben lang alkohol
trinken ohne damit ein problem zu
bekommen allerdings solltet ihr euch der
gefahren bewusst sein
cannabis eine tödliche überdosis durch
cannabis wurde noch nie festgestellt
laut der studie fällt sie unter die
kategorie geringes risiko die gefahr die
durch diese droge ausgeht ist dass viele
menschen ihre langzeitschäden
unterschätzen
bei beinahe täglichen konsum über monate
oder sogar jahre hinweg hat cannabis
durchaus negative einflüsse auf das
lernverhalten und die kognitiven
fähigkeiten einer person wer breit mit
einem auto fährt verdoppelt außerdem
seine chancen einen unfall zu
verursachen
damit ist kann das ist natürlich bei
weitem kein so großes problem für die
gesellschaft wie alkohol
man sollte sich dennoch bewusst sein
dass man nicht vollkommen funktional ist
während mannheim ist oder wie ein
professor der mellon universität ist
ausdrückte zitat wenn man mehr als die
hälfte seiner wachen stunden über jahre
hinweg hai ist dann erhöht das nicht
gerade die chancen den pulitzer preis zu
gewinnen oder krebs zu heilen zitat ende
ein großes problem in der legalisierung
von cannabis ist dass wir nicht wissen
wie die gesellschaft die droge benutzen
wird wenn cannabis anstelle von alkohol
verwendet wird dann würden wir durch
eine legalisierung viel gewinnen wenn
aber cannabis zusätzlich zur alkohol
genommen wird erhöht sich zum beispiel
das risiko einen unfall zu verursachen
um das 23-fache denn verschiedene
rauschgifte gleichzeitig einzunehmen
führt oft zu unvorhersehbaren
auswirkungen auf den menschlichen körper
nikotin nikotin ist die droge die zu den
weltweit meisten toten führt rauchen
zerstört den körper auf mehrere arten
und weisen fällt in die kategorie hohes
persönliches risiko
neben krebs der für mehr als allein
110.000 euro pro jahr in deutschland
sorgt erhöht sich auch das
herzinfarktrisiko immens diabetes
leukämie nierenversagen und herz
kreislauf störungen sind weitere häufige
folgen und sogar für die allgemeinheit
ist rauchen schlecht auf der skala die
die gefahr für andere menschen beurteilt
ist das rauchen immer noch ein risiko
nikotin ist für viele menschen eine
schnelle mehr oder weniger billige
methode um herunterzufahren aber auf
lange sicht ist die zigarettensucht
vielleicht die schlimmste krankheit
unserer heutigen gesellschaft kokain
kokain fällt in die kategorie hohes
risiko für die eigene person
es führt zu einer steigerung des
blutdrucks und der herzschlagrate es
erhöht das risiko eines herzinfarkts
oder eines schlaganfalls bei leuten die
sonst komplett gesund sind außerdem für
kokain häufig zu psychosen und
temporären paranoia anpacken auf lange
sicht ist kokain sogar weniger
gefährlich als zigaretten zu rauchen
aber während der phase werden menschen
gewaltbereiter oder wollen sich sogar
umbringen ich hatte in meinem eigenen
bekannten greifen ganz ganz schlimm fall
heroin auch heroin fällt in die
kategorie hose risiko dass extrem
einfach ist an einer überdosis zu
sterben heroinsüchtige menschen gewöhnen
sich schnell an das haider droge und
nehmen immer mehr bis der körper die
menge nicht mehr verarbeiten kann
ein weiteres risiko besteht in den oft
dreckigen spritzen der ruinen benutzer
infiziert sich häufig mit hiv und
anderen krankheiten
die droge macht extrem süchtig weswegen
die hemmschwelle um an mehr heroin
heranzukommen stark herabgesetzt wird
oft werden verbrechen begangen oder der
eigene körper verkauft um mehr heroin zu
bekommen
meth methamphetamin hat auf kurze sicht
ein ähnliches risiko wie kokain menschen
werden paranoid gewaltbereit bekommen
häufiger herzinfarkte und können tage
lang nicht schlafen allerdings werden
zusätzlich noch schäden am gehirn
verursacht irreparable kognitive
einschränkungen oder so parkinson sind
bekannte folgen dafür fühlen sich die
user kurzzeitig energetischer und
fokussierter obwohl die gehirnleistung
auf einem high extrem herr absinkt mesz
stellt ein erhöhtes risiko für einen
selbst und ein risiko für die umgebung
dar
ls die lsd oder magic mushrooms also
magische pilze führen zu mentalen
störungen psychosen dem verlust der
realität oder in seltenen fällen sogar
zu langzeit traumata eine überdosis
durch halluzinogene ist sehr selten
häufiger sind unfälle durch eine
gestörte umgebungs wahrnehmung
interessant an lsd und magic mushrooms
ist das sehr geringe suchtrisiko im
vergleich zu den meisten anderen drogen
bisher erklärt habe harley halluzinogene
sind in nicht kontrollierten umgebung
und dennoch gefährlich und können zu
sehr schlechten erfahrungen führen da
glaubt man zum teil dieser gesehen zu
haben außerdem sind in seltenen fällen
mentale langzeitschäden möglich sie
fallen deshalb in die kategorie risiko
wenn euch das thema drogen interessiert
dann kann ich euch ein super spannendes
buch empfehlen tage der toten handelt
von der mexikanischen drogenmafia kein
buch für schwache nerven
das beste daran ist aber dass er es
kostenlos als hörbuch bekommen könnt
wenn ihr hier oben klickt dann kommt ihr
zur orgel dort bekommt man mit einem
probe account auch direkt an hörbuch zum
testen vollkommen kostenlos und ohne
versteckte fallen das finde ich super
selbst wenn er beim probe account löscht
dürft ihr das hörbuch erhalten zum
hörbuch tage der toten kommt er eben da
oben und im ersten link in den die
beschreibung ansonsten erfahrt ihr hier
noch mehr zum thema alkohol mit einem
kleinen selbstversuch das könnt ihr euch
eben hier ansehen und zur pixum app und
zum blog geht es hier unten und was man
ihr welche drogen werden vollkommen über
oder unterschätzt diskutiert dass mit
mir unten in den kopf
ansonsten wie immer bis dann bleibt dran
[Musik]